et on en vient à présent on va plus loin
avec Marie Roger billoa directrice du
groupe africain international bonjour
Marie Roger bon je refais le Mariotti
Chronicles International France 24
bonjour Antoine on est donc à trois
semaines un des meetum aux États-Unis
des élections mimanda qui s'annonce plus
indécis que jamais en temps normal c'est
le parti au pouvoir qui a le plus à
perdre sauf que l'économie américaine et
surtout que l'économie américaine est
actuellement dans la finade avec
l'inflation sauf que cette fois et bien
l'opposition républicaine paraît être
tirée une balle dans le pied en
promettant de remettre en cause le droit
à l'avortement écoutez Joe Biden saisir
la balle au bon
si les républicains parviennent à leur
fin et mettent en place un interdit au
niveau national l'endroit où vous vivez
en Amérique n'aura plus d'importance
mais soyons clairs signent telle loi
devait être adoptée dans les années à
venir
j'y mettrai mon veto
voilà c'était hier alors d'un meeting
démocrate à Washington Marie Roger les
démocrates ont raison d'afficher comme
priorité en cas de victoire
l'inscription dans la loi de
l'avortement ils peuvent les inscrire de
ce qui leur semble porteur
surtout que tout le monde les données
perdants c'est on vient de parler
l'inflation mais même
l'impopularité de maeden faisait
craindre le pire et donc là c'est une
opportunité c'est un sujet de société
qui visiblement les préoccupes davantage
que les tribulations de Monsieur Trump
et ça pour moi c'est une surprise parce
que
Trump fait à peu près sur tout ce qu'il
veut il
entrave il enfreint toutes les lois
qu'il peut enfreindre et il est toujours
en liberté il n'a absolument aucun
problème c'est à dire on va revenir sur
le quatrième dans un instant
effectivement mais en tout cas sur cette
question de l'avortement vous considère
tactiquement c'est une effectivement une
bonne idée de leur part mais mais
au-delà de ça il y a vraiment un
problème fondamental et une question de
principe qui qui s'impose d'une certaine
électorale démocrate mais oui c'est les
sondages l'indique c'est les sondages
qui nous font savoir que les Américaines
tiennent à ce droit et que c'est quelque
chose de central et plus important que
les débats politiques en républicains et
démocrate et justement c'était adhésion
est trans partisane et c'est pour ça que
il tire sur cette fuite c'est le temps
qui peut je crois que c'est surtout ça
qu'est-ce qui peut marcher actuellement
qu'est-ce qui peut les sortir de la
panade actuellement voilà c'est un thème
qui tombe très bien il faut dire Antoine
que la possibilité donnée à à chaque
État désormais d'interdire l'avortement
sa décision de la Cour suprême ne fait
pas forcément les affaires des
républicains non pas forcément et
d'ailleurs on vient de le dire mais si
Joe Biden assiste là dessus c'est bien
que de l'autre côté ça les embête un
petit peu et ça ça les titille il est
intéressant de voir d'ailleurs que dans
la plupart des clips de campagne un peu
partout dans le pays les des
républicains n'en parle pas beaucoup de
l'avortement il se concentre sur
l'immigration sur d'autres problèmes
évidemment sur l'économie alors oui
c'est un c'est un problème d'ailleurs
Joe Biden dans ses discours encore cette
semaine il s'adressait à la foule ils
disaient mais rappelez-vous un petit peu
l'effet que ça vous a fait quand vous
avez entendu la décision de la Cour
suprême les froids la colère
l'inquiétude l'incrédulité que ça a
provoqué chez vous et on voit d'ailleurs
des
républicaines qui ont toujours voté
républicains dans leur vie qui
commencent à dire à témoigner dans les
médias en disant cette fois-ci moi je
vais voter démocrate parce que je ne
peux pas je ne peux pas ce n'est pas qui
je suis d'interdire l'avortement de
revenir sur 50 années de de droit des
femmes c'est my body my choice comme
Elie c'est mon corps c'est mon choix on
peut pas revenir sur des choses pareil
donc les républicains d'un côté et bien
flatte un peu l'ego des plus des plus
énervés chez eux et donc ça ça
fonctionne le anti-avortement ça c'est
un débat plus important que chez nous de
manière générale et en même temps et
bien ça leur tire une balle dans le pied
parce qu'il passe pour aux yeux de
certains pour un peu pour pour des
arrières traduit dans les yeux on a au
Kansas notamment qui est un état très
très conservateur très républicain et
dans l'inscription dans les listes
électorales parce que c'est que parfois
vous pouvez déclarer si vous êtes
démocrates ou républicain et on a vu
d'ailleurs après la décision de la Cour
suprême qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
démocrates et de démocrates et notamment
de fin de démocrates qui se sont
inscrits notamment sur sur ces listes
alors après il y a des petites sujets
quand même d'inquiétude pour les
démocrates c'est que notamment les
femmes indépendantes et bien été
beaucoup plus à même de voter pour les
démocrates il y a quelques semaines
encore au moment où on parlez notamment
sur la référendum du Kansas aujourd'hui
beaucoup moins ça a rebasculé côté
républicain et on n'est plus qu'à trois
semaines du scrutin ça devient un petit
peu compliqué pour eux surtout qu'on
voit que une actualité chasse l'autre
finalement et que désormais dans les
sondages d'opinion même si les chiffres
diffèrent on voit bien que l'économie
notamment l'inflation sont devant dans
les termes dans les priorités de
préoccupations des Américains mais que
avant même le droit des femmes et donc
l'avortement il est aussi l'immigration
et aussi la criminalité et que ça arrive
parfois un petit peu une enquête du New
thème se disait que c'était seulement 5%
des personnes qui estimaient que c'était
une priorité alors une autre enquête du
17% oui il faut être un peu prudent sur
les chiffres mais en tout cas ça ne
revient jamais en tête donc il faudra
voir si si ça commence à évoluer dans
les dans les semaines qui viennent un
débat qui survient alors que vous l'avez
dit Marie Roger les dossiers
s'accumulent contre Donald Trump déjà
soupçonné de fraude fiscale à New York
d'avoir incité aussi c'est partisans à
prendre d'assaut le Capitole d'être
parti de la maison blanche avec des
documents classés secret défense le
voilà accusé d'avoir censuré les
informations sur le covid 19 contraire à
ces discours inquiétant d'être on s'en
souvient à minimiser la pandémie ses
affaires elles vont peser sur les
mi-temps Marie Roger alors ça c'est
vraiment le serpent mais c'est à dire
lorsqu'on regarde les États-Unis je suis
étonné que je peux j'ai l'impression que
je suis la seule à être totalement
scandalisé par ceux qui se passe depuis
même avant l'élection de Trump il se
personnage comment il a pu être élu et
tout ce qu'il a fait depuis
même si évidemment on sait qu'il a des
partisans et
fanatisé tout ce qu'on veut une espèce
de chef de secte mais sur le plan légal
mais mais c'est un c'est une valise de
le problème
d'intérêt pour avoir hébergé des agents
des services spéciaux dans ses propres
hôtels Trump a des frais somptuctuaires
on parle de notes d'hôtel pour aller à
plus de 1000 euros la nuit quand même
mais ça c'est les tapis il y a une liste
de conflits et de et de délits et même
de crimes concernant Trump et ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui ça fait quoi depuis
2016 on arrive même pas à
l'amener à la justice bon c'est vrai
qu'on a il a quand même été à empêcher
une piste deux fois et c'est vrai qu'on
oublie ça il y a une procédure politique
les plumes d'un canard tout et c'est et
c'est quand même très important parce
que je crois que le monde entier regarde
la démocratie américaine et voit si elle
est crédible si elle arrive à gérer
quelqu'un qui a fait un coup d'état où
il y a eu des morts des agents fédéraux
qui ont été tués et
voilà et tout tout ramène à lui et on
est là on dirait qu'on a peur de Trump
et que Anita une institution toutes les
institutions ont peur il faut dire que
il faut dire que la justice américaine
permet aussi un nombre incalculable de
voies de recours et aussi d'arrangement
parce que très souvent les les affaires
se décident dans les huis clos des
bureaux avant de se retrouver devant le
tribunal
lorsqu'il embarque des documents
confidentiels et de ce qui est
totalement illégal il a encore la
possibilité de dire non je ne donne pas
il faudrait qu'on a on a pointé
particulier
il a presque réussi ça jusqu'à ce qu'il
y a un appel
un pays effectivement encore une fois où
le règne de la loi est censé prévaloir
ça semble absolument incroyable un débat
qui survient alors que donc on l'a dit
les dossiers s'accumulent et d'autant
plus que Donald Trump a réussi à faire
des idées nombre de candidats qu'il
soutenaient par les électeurs
républicains lors des primaires Antoine
ce sont donc ces candidats à lui qui
seront posés au démocrates dans le
nombre de circonscriptions pas forcément
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les
démocrates d'ailleurs oui c'est quand
même assez amusant de voir un homme qui
a financé autant de campagne démocrate
dans le passé y compris de ses
principaux adversaires aujourd'hui ou
dans le passé récent avoir complètement
vampirisé ce parti républicain avoir mis
la main dessus lui qui a jamais été un
fervent républicain loin de là aux
États-Unis jamais un président n'aura
pesé autant sur le choix des candidats
sénateurs représentants gouverneur que
lors de ce scrutin des mitermes de 200
il a fait battre tous les candidats au
poste de représentants qui n'avaient qui
avait soutenu notamment la procédure
engagée contre lui après la somme du
Capitole aliéné par tous ceux qui
pouvaient avoir je vois un peu
d'historantecordante comme Disney par
exemple et bien son prix les foudres de
Trump et évidemment de toute la vague
qui arrive derrière les fameux énervés
dans vous parliez quoi voilà les détails
d'avoir face à eux des candidats parfois
complètement voilà fanatisés aux
électeurs et adepte surtout des vérités
parallèles alors justement c'est ce qui
est intéressant c'est que on voit bien
que ce sont en effet les candidats de
Trump et que jamais d'ailleurs un ancien
président n'a participé à autant de
rassemblement de meeting que lors de
cette campagne donc si il perd ce sera
aussi sa défaite donc c'est c'est un
risque après s'il gagne ce serait aussi
sa victoire et peut-être potentiellement
un tremplin important pour 2024 la
prochaine présidentielle sachant que
pour l'instant ça reste le candidat
naturel du parti mais pour répondre à
votre question Raphaël il y a aussi
quelques pompes du parti républicain qui
s'inquiète un peu et qui nous disent
voilà ils craignent que la qualité
médiocre finalement de certains
candidats qui ont été promus ou
que mon anglais désigné par Donald Trump
et bien pour écouter au parti le
républicain la victoire dans l'une des
deux chambres et donc ça il pourrait le
payer cher aussi et donc il y a aussi
des voix discordantes mais comme on le
disait elles sont de moins en moins
nombreuses mais cela dit on parle de son
de sa candidature en 2024 et de plus en
plus de gens qui pensent qu'il pourra
pas il va pas se présenter même pas pour
les leçons juridiques juridique
judiciaire tout simplement parce qu'il
n'aura plus accès à tous les
financements de de ces fans et de des
milliardaires qui le soutiennent parce
que cet argent sera comptabilisé
officiellement comme fond de campagne
alors qu'actuellement il en dispose
comme il veut donc se souvenir qu'il
avait notamment étonné lors de son
élection en 2016 en faisant une campagne
relativement low cost à l'époque parce
qu'il avait misé sur les réseaux sociaux
et non pas sur les spots faut pas
oublier que à la dernière élection
présidentielle on a beau nous voir ces
choses absolument délirantes ce qui se
passe aux États-Unis à la dernière
élection présidentielle qu'il a certes
perdu il a eu plus de voix que lors de
la foi il a été élu il a eu plus de voix
que Barack Obama lors de la première
fois il a été beaucoup plus
d'argent aussi Antoine alors de ça quand
deuxième candidature de la première et
donc ça c'est quand même sont comme des
chiffres sur lesquels qui doivent
alerter les démocrates parce que c'est
un véritable danger que les démocrates
ont un petit peu du mal à remobiliser un
petit peu leur troupes juste avant on
parlait très rapidement on parlait de
l'économie Joe Biden se targue d'avoir
créé 10 millions d'emplois depuis qu'il
est pouvoir donc depuis moins de 2 ans
donc plus de 200000 rien que le mois
dernier mois de septembre mais il
n'arrive pas à concrétiser ça
concrètement comme comme un appel d'air
même ces plans d'investissements
notamment pour les infrastructures de
plusieurs centaines de milliards la
réussite en 2023 et il arrive pas à à
ton capitaliser de finaliser donc il
joue beaucoup sur l'avortement notamment
et sur la démocratie mais ça c'est un
peu c'est toujours économiste comme
avait dit bill Clinton à l'époque à
George Bush père on en vient à cette
sujet c'est une guerre déjà qualifiée de
désastre humanitaires dans un pays qui
n'a guère été épargné ces dernières
décennies l'Éthiopie voit ses forces
armées à nouveau à l'offensive depuis
fin août dans la province rebelle du
Tigré écoutait le constat en fait pour
l'ONU Antonio Guterres
de situations
en Éthiopie devient incontrôlable la
violence et la destruction Athènes des
niveaux alarmants le tissu social est en
train de se déchirer
les hostilités dans la région du Tigre
et en Éthiopie doivent cesser maintenant
y compris avec le retrait immédiat et le
désengagement des forces armées
érythrées en Éthiopie
une guerre à huit clos dont il n'existe
pas ou peu d'images Marie Roger à
l'origine il a la paire d'influence du
Front de libération du peuple du Tigré
longtemps au pouvoir face à la remise en
cause par l'actuel Premier ministre bien
armée du système politique
ethnocentrique qui était en vigueur
depuis le milieu des années 90 tout à
fait c'est très important de rappeler
quand même au début que
habillé à Ahmed n'est pas un fauteuil de
guerre en fait c'était il est arrivé
comme homme de paix et en tout cas déjà
avec l'Érythrée mais aussi sur le plan
intérieur il a libéré énormément de
prisonniers politiques mais des
centaines sinon des milliers parce que
c'est là qu'on réalisait qu'il y en
avait beaucoup il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de gens emprisonnés il a libéré
beaucoup de gens il a fait venir des
opposants qui étaient des opportunistes
emblématique qui était par exemple aux
États-Unis pour qu'il vienne prendre des
responsabilités il avait une espèce
climat d'apaisement mais ceux qui
avaient dirigé le pays pendant plus de
30 ans n'était pas content de cette
perte d'influence on a essayé
d'assassiner à bien mettre effectivement
de tentative de coup d'État il y a eu
aussi des tentatives de putsch régionaux
du côté de la Smara donc il est
partiellement originaire aussi les oraux
puisque la moitié oraux ont été sous ont
révélés ces pires ennemis puisque c'est
eux qui ont lancé les révoltes les plus
sanglantes et voilà on a tué le chef
d'état-major éthiopien enfin il y a eu
il y a eu des choses absolument énorme
donc il a réagi avec beaucoup de vigueur
et beaucoup de violence trop
certainement aujourd'hui il est comme
emprisonné c'est une espèce de piège
parce que là on sait plus comment en
sortir il a puni il a voulu punir
l'Érythrée non pas le
tigre et maintenant c'est du blocus
lorsqu'on parle de ça même pas assez
c'est surtout pour dire à quel point
c'est la misère et que 40% des tigréens
sont menacés de famine etc c'est
l'ironie de l'histoire Antoine partie
qui refuse le cesser le saut aujourd'hui
et bien c'est précisément le prix Nobel
de la Paix à biarned avec pour bras armé
c'est les ennemis d'hier avec qui il
s'est réconcilié précisément pour
obtenir d'ailleurs cette distinction les
érythréens oui parce que tirer était au
pouvoir pendant pendant 27 ans en effet
mais à l'époque il y a une végaire de 20
ans avec l'érythrite est une ancienne
province d'ailleurs de l'Éthiopie et
c'est vrai que vous avez raison de dire
Madame que quand il est arrivé c'était
en faiseur de paix au début il a
sécurité comme d'un pays très endetté un
taux de chômage extrêmement élevé et
puis avec des conflits aussi ethniques
importants et qu'il a mis en place
beaucoup de réformes qu'il a mis en
effet en place cette paix avec avec son
voisin et donc il a eu ce fameux prix
Nobel de la paix en 2019 sauf que dès
2019 fut maintenant Swatch
l'organisation de défense des droits de
l'homme dit il y a des dérives aussi au
niveau des droits de l'homme notamment
au niveau de la liberté d'expression qui
est de plus en plus muselée et ce qui
est intéressant c'est de voir aussi que
finalement cet accord de paix ça aussi
été une alliance contre les tigréens qui
est donc une région tout au nord du pays
qui est frontalière de l'Erythrée et
cette armée est impliquée directement
dans les combats qui se passent au tigré
les responsables tigrés indices
d'ailleurs qu'il y a des opérations
conjointes entre l'armée de l'Éthiopie
l'armée de l'Erythrée en ce moment même
notamment depuis la reprise des combats
le 24 août dernier dans cette zone là
donc c'est c'est ce sont des combats
assez importants et d'ailleurs les
organisations de défense de droits de
l'homme je citer tout à l'heure du
manoir dénonce des crimes de guerre dans
ces régions là notamment de la part de
l'armée Ethiopienne de l'armée
érythréenne mais pas que les forces de
la Mara aussi qui est une province juste
au-dessous du juste au-dessus du tigre
on parle de Massac on passe de viole de
masse d'attaque délibéré il y a aussi
des problèmes de l'autre côté mais il y
a un véritable blackout sur place on ne
peut pas y aller et on sait très très
peu de choses de ce qu'il y en sort et
donc il faut compter de ce qui en parler
c'est bien pour cela merci beaucoup
Antoine Mariotti merci Marie Roger
billoha d'avoir été avec nous on va plus
loin c'est terminé on se retrouve dans
moins de 3 minutes pour un nouveau
journal dans Paris directrice avec
[Musique]